this video is brought to you by
Skillshare what's up wisecrack jared
here on the set of earthling cinema
which if you didn't know is its own
channel now we gotten a lot of requests
to do castlevania after its second
season dropped and gotta say it's pretty
good
we loved its artwork the references to
the games and some great voice
performances getting the good people of
grey [ __ ] to commit murder for you let's
see how you do on your own but as we
tried to discover a philosophy the show
we fell a little bit short the show's
writer warren ellis clearly puts a lot
of thought into his work but as far as
we can tell they haven't really fully
formed in castlevania yet
now despite that we still wanted to talk
about some of the ideas we noticed
cropping up that may be further fleshed
out in ensuing seasons so welcome to
this wisecrack half-baked edition on
netflix is castlevania and as usual
spoilers ahead now first a quick recap
its 1455 in the land of wil akhiya and
dracula has just found out that his
human wife has been burned at the stake
for practicing science or is the
catholic church like to call it
witchcraft
she called it all science lab lisa
tempesh of lucca was so far
and she just couldn't see that it was
all given to her by Satan so naturally
he goes all John wick and promises to
return in exactly one year to kill all
mankind one year later and sure enough
an army of the night descends on the
country meanwhile Trevor Belmont the
last drunken descendant of a family of
vampire hunters helps a group of nomads
the speakers find their missing friend
Sipho who just so happens to be an
actual wizard
they team up to fight the forces of
darkness with Dracula's estranged
half-human son Alucard until they
finally have almost all the playable
characters from Castlevania three r.i.p
grant dinasty the second season explores
the motivations of the various generals
Dracula has amassed while Trevor Sipho
and Alucard sit around in a library
arguing like a bunch of nerds
they finally find a way into Dracula's
castle kick some ass and after a few
attacks straight out of a Castlevania
boss fight Dracula surrenders his life
to Alucard after realizing what a dick
he's been the first idea we found the
show exploring but couldn't quite mold
into a definitive thesis was on humanism
I give us one like an 8 out of 10 Warren
Ellis is a self-confessed humanist which
is the belief in the value of a human
beings own agency and autonomy humanists
prized rationality and empiricism over
superstition as you might guess
humanists are not big fans of religion
and the Catholic Church is a frequent
target with all their historic hatred of
science and people choosing when and
whom they want to have sex with so it
makes sense that Ellis put this theme in
a show set in the 15th century because
let's be honest it wasn't exactly the
high point for the Catholic Church
Ellis's humanism can be seen in the way
science and humanity are portrayed as
the true heroes of the story one of the
clever ways he accomplishes this is by
taking your typical christ-like traits
and giving them to humans for example as
a scientist Lisa wants to learn from
Dracula so she can heal the sick not
unlike the miracles of Jesus when she
burns on the cross she begs Dracula to
forgive the people because they know not
what they do
reflecting Jesus's famous words on the
cross
in contrast to the church where ordained
men with the knowledge of God need to
Shepherd the ignorant flock Lisa
believes knowledge should be shared with
humanity for everyone's benefit
despite being set long before the
Enlightenment her kind of thinking would
be found in philosophers like David Hume
and his treatise on human nature or
jean-jacques Rousseau's amel or on
education both central to humanists
thought this belief that shared
knowledge can help mankind is also
contrasted in both the Belmont library
and Dracula's accumulated knowledge
which are treated as precious things to
be guarded a big part of humanism
reflected in the show is altruism and
love for your fellow man it's because of
his love for his mother and her love for
people that Alucard teams up with Sipho
and belmont to defend the humans and
even kill his own father because it is
what my mother would have wanted psifas
love for people is what motivates her to
fight while it's Trevor's lack of family
that makes him the wandering alcoholic
that we see but trevor is later
convinced to give up his misanthropic
ways because of his feelings for Sipho
in the short time we have known each
other you have rediscovered yourself the
villains in the show are also motivated
by love or at least the lack of it
Dracula losing his wife is the inciting
factor of the whole show the two
characters were this motivation of love
or black of it is most important isn't
Isaac and Hector the to humans who side
with the vampires they both hate
humanity enough to want to see it
destroyed purely because they love they
once had was taken from them
Hector's beloved animals were always
killed by humans and the man Isaac loved
turned that love against him I love you
too
that's why I do this this is how I love
you the reverse is shown to be a
redeeming quality to the show argues
that love is the single most humanizing
and dehumanizing force in the world and
while we find it hard to argue at that
sentiment there's just not much more to
say the second pitch we explored was on
the organization of knowledge now we're
gonna give this one like a 6 out of 10
the idea is basically what it sounds
like it refers to the different ways we
arrange and store the stuff we know and
these different methods are central to
the show's conflict let's start off by
looking at a prominent theme in season
one science versus religion lisa is
burned at the stake by the church
because she was a scientist and for the
church any science they don't understand
is clearly witchcraft then there's Sipho
and the speaker's a nomadic group who
bears some resemblance to the Romani
people or Roma an itinerant group who
were dispersed throughout Europe and the
Dark Ages
and largely remained so today the
speakers go from town to town spreading
their message of altruism and offering
aid to those in need I told you it was
necessary to offer aid to the people
like many nomadic people throughout the
ages their histories and tradition are
oral meaning they have no written
language to record their past but my
father once got into a fight with one
through speakers do not fight when he
tried to convince the speaker to have
your oral history transcribed on paper
their knowledge is kept and organized by
elders passing teachings and stories
down from generation to generation
because of this psifas people are the
custodians of knowledge that has
otherwise been lost to history
this one has the identical roots and
some of these structure of high
remembrance I think give I haven't heard
for Demick the speaker's oral tradition
might explain why Sipho is able to use a
type of magic that other humans can't
like the speaker's the Belmonts have
passed down their family knowledge from
generation to generation but they prefer
writing it down in books and such the
enormous Belmont library hidden beneath
the family home is a repository for
centuries of knowledge where the three
heroes spent almost the whole of the
second season the knowledge inside does
eventually help them defeat
ocula even if Alucard isn't a fan it's
like a museum dedicated to the
extermination of my peoples and not
thrilled we even see how Sipho and
Trevor mock each other's method of
passing on knowledge only to see them
require it later
Seifer resists the need for written
history but admits later that I am
coming to the conclusion that my people
are idiots
while Trevor jokes about the foolishness
of the speaker's oral tradition and the
end though it's psifas oral histories
that contain the key to opening the
family vault
I guess the special trick was passed
down the generations
then there's Dracula described as a
polymath by Alucard Dracula hoard
scientific knowledge much like the
Belmonts performing experiments that
result in teleportation and shattered
windows that make you functionally
omniscient Dracula's knowledge is
organized not just by written documents
and books like the Belmonts but his own
memory similar to the way the speakers
retained their knowledge in the first
episode we see his laboratory and learn
how isolated he's become in his work
Tulisa then convinces him to reconnect
with the human world and to share his
knowledge maybe I can teach you to like
people again but unlike Sipho and Trevor
he after some convincing starts to share
that knowledge with the outside world
unfortunately that doesn't work out too
well because when he shares his
scientific discoveries well which leads
us to the church they store their
knowledge too but in a hierarchy with
the Pope on top God's will is only to be
understood by ordained men and it's
their interpretation of written
knowledge ie the Bible that matters most
to holding tanks and goddesses
[Music]
the church uses this knowledge only held
by a select few to wield power over the
illiterate masses and this is where we
thought we could say that castlevanias
treatment of knowledge bears some
resemblance to philosopher Michelle
fucose theory of knowledge and power
this Lex Luthor look-alike explored
knowledge and power as separate entities
that were inextricably linked for
Foucault everything has some form of
power now some things more than others
and it's not always obvious how that
power influences the world for instance
as you confess to a priest you may think
of the priest as having power over you
since he's judging you but to Foucault
it's a bit more nuanced than that as you
confess your sin you create knowledge
perhaps the knowledge that you are
playing your switch during Mass the
knowledge generated by confessing may
create guilt in you regardless of the
priests judgment the knowledge you
generated in the confession is what
exerts power over you not only the
priest shaking his head at the notion
that you spammed Isabelle's fishing pole
basically the priest could stay silent
and you'd still feel like because the
act of confessing itself holds power in
Castlevania we get a good look at how
knowledge interacts with power but not
necessarily this endless cycle of power
and knowledge influencing each other
that Foucault was talking about the
church is threatened by Lisa and
Dracula's power knowledge because their
science would reduce the bishops
religious power so he has Lisa killed to
stop her how can engines of the devil be
physical the show constantly suggests
that knowledge is a power that must be
maintained to save your genius your
knowledge and your will without question
I am just a forge master yours is the
wisdom of Ages it pretty much boils down
to knowledge is power as in I know these
magic words that can set you on fire
which is kind of cliche and not quite
what Foucault meant maybe if the church
had to grapple with how their godly
knowledge in part controlled them this
pitch might have worked or if Trevor and
Sipho explored what their own methods of
keeping knowledge meant besides using a
magic mirror it also might have worked
better the final pitch we got is class
and I
this one like a five out of ten one of
the themes in Bram Stoker's original
novel is class it sells the story of a
wealthy count in Romania who literally
lives off the blood of the peasants he
then calls for a lawyer so he can buy
property in London and do the same thing
there Stoker who was Irish lived most of
his life in London and if you know the
British they are obsessed with class
well at least that's what our resident
Brit Leo tells us the show's writer
warren alice also british explores class
struggles in his comics like transmitter
Politan and trees so it's no surprise
that this theme appears in castlevania
the show paints a graphic picture of the
feudal class system in milwaukee a--
where the few peasants we see literally
goats
so you said Oh
bozhe Saul says how he says well she's
made a shame and hate the rich families
the great house isn't crazy Vlad Dracula
[Music]
the capital all run bother great houses
the rich families like the Belmonts
think they're better than the poor even
the vampires have a form of hierarchy
with Dracula as their leader
the vampire generals below him and the
winged Horrors beneath them it's vaguely
feudalistic with vampires bound to serve
the vampire who turned them like
Carmilla before she broke the rules and
murdered her master I was bound to him
[Applause]
this bond they have or fealty as it was
called is similar to the way vassals
were obligated to their Lord in feudal
systems Carmilla also agitates against
this class structure because she sees
herself as better and more capable than
the rest of the vampires in the end she
even takes Hector as a pet to prove her
superiority characters who are born into
power typically through inherited
knowledge wealth or both are put at the
top of the food chain literally while
those at the bottom are treated like
dirt when the peasants in the tavern
discovered Trevor is a Belmont they
attack him out of class hatred and the
speakers are treated like dirt because
of their status as lowly nomads this
class structure dictates every
characters position in the show now
while class is an overriding theme in
the original book about Dracula and is
present in Castlevania - we don't really
have much more to say it's discussed by
characters and shown to be a thing we
just couldn't find a way to show how it
develops into a coherent theme or
exploration so as you can see there's a
lot of smart things to talk about in
Castlevania and maybe it's just too
early in the show for all of us to point
to some kind of definitive thesis either
way the show is dope and we can't wait
to see what season three offers now
whether you're looking to horde
knowledge to better yourself or better
humanity you guys got to give a skill
share a tribe skill share is an online
learning community that offers classes
and business design tech and more skill
share is the best place to learn new
things to make 2019 your year I've been
jonesing to take a class from who I
consider to be the best animators on all
of YouTube in a nutshell or if you guys
already have a great idea but just don't
know how to share it with the world
they've got presentation essentials how
to share ideas that inspire action
premium membership gives you unlimited
access to high-quality classes on must
know topics so you can improve your
skills and join the classes and
communities that are just right for you
and your new year's goals Skillshare has
been hugely supportive of the work we do
and right now they're giving two months
for free to the first 500 fans who sign
up using the link in the description so
join the millions of students learning
today and head to skl sh / wisecrack 17
and as always thanks for watching guys
[Music]